Alright guys, so here is another example for the holy grail strategy and for this I'm going to use the continuation purge or the
You know the ABC or the ABCD combination with this you can say that it's a continuation purge, but
If you are familiar with my concepts, you can call them ABC or ABCD as well
So on the daily time frame, we're gonna go from daily to hourly to five minute to frame our trade
so over here we have this external liquidity taken out and in the discount we have this
Fairbody gap right so now let's go to the hourly time frame and we have to wait for a shift in the market structure, right and
See what has happened here
We got a break to a very low low low or high low low low right so that is a shift in the market structure as well
Considering the fact that we have taken out the objective so now what we want to wait for is a continuation purge
right and
Over here, what do we have we have this
Bicyte right or a
High over here the indicator failed to do so so that is a high
So we wait for price to take out that high once that happens you want to mark out the move
We want to scout out the market maker model inside here, right and look at when the
When the purge happened at around eight so remember when I say that the purges happen roughly from eight to
10 30 right that is like your sweet spot it can happen anytime of the day right but that is what you want to look for so
Going into the five minute time frame now first off you simply want to mark out your
Consolidation phase so we have this beautiful consolidation phase right with with these equal lows here. That is our clear draw on liquidity
Right so now we wait for is a shift in the market structure and over here
We have a shift in the market structure, but there's no fair value gap right and there is these
This equal highs over here right and this autoblock didn't take out any liquidity here
So this is not a valid autoblock here, right?
So you want to keep these things in mind you want to wait for a clean shift in the market structure with fair value gap
Fairway gap is very necessary here guys
So we wait for price to give us something here and right away. You can see we took out these equal highs
Over here right this buildup of liquidity this engineered liquidity. We have this shift in the market structure
Right you have this fairly gap and also this fairly gap like this whole fairly gap
Right your entry should be from this fbg your stop goes here and you target simply this
But since that your risk reward is 1.61. We need at least two rr
Right so you want to just decrease your stop until you get one to two, but your target remains the same
All right, so let's see how this plays out
We tap in and we have a small scalp on the five minute time frame
So now we are in the scalping territory
All right, so we're gonna get like one to two or one two three or four max out of these trades
Even sometimes one to four as well
But you can see that you have to look for these guys look
In normal trader once he saw this structure break
He could have taken the entry from I don't know from somewhere here because there's no further gap here
Right
There's no clean auto block look at the so many candles here, but then price but I did it created these equal highs over here
So now these these concepts are not like
ABC or ABCD trading strategy, right? You don't just follow the rules like a robot
No, you have to look at these things you have to look for a clean shift in market structure
Look at this we took out the liquidity and we didn't have any double top, right?
We don't have any highs around here. So once you get the shift we can simply take our entry here
There's fairly gap here
There's a breaker block here as well that you could have utilized
But fairly gap is my best friend for this strategy
So
Consolidation is all you need to identify and you can get a setup out of it, right? Like this is like the
The best strategy guys this I don't think there's something better out there. That is better than this. Okay, so
Yeah, we look for a continuation purge here. You can see and that's about it
So let me give you guys one more example